on va parler du numérique qui se mettent
au service finalement dû du patrimoine
pour faire parler les vieilles pierres
avec un projet dont on n'a pas fini
d'entendre parler en train de marquer
c'est le projet matrix c'est ça
ces matrices ses aînés au mois novembre
en fait c'est un projet parisien né dans
les locaux de l'école 42 c'est une école
de codage que chez nous non à paris
d'accord en fait ça réunit une trentaine
d'étudiants qui viennent de neuf écoles
différentes et il travaille pour le
château du clos de vougeot et l'abbaye
contenait donc en bourgogne d'accord et
le but s'est installé le numérique et
les nouvelles technologies dans ces
lieux vieux de plus de 900 ans
ok on va comprendre pourquoi ça va
changer finalement de nos visites
classiques d'ici quelques secondes le
temps peut-être de voir les élèves
travailler parce qu'il ya toute une
équipe
on va vous montrer quelques images
regardez c'est le projet matrix
[Musique]
alors depuis trois jours faire à caton
pour trouver des projets et des équipes
des innovations avec eux
et
[Musique]
c'est très intéressant parce qu'en même
temps on voit une nouvelle écriture du
journalisme l'emmener sur le web c'est
un petit peu différent de nos
traditionnels écrans voyez vous on est
dans quelque chose qui change c'est une
belle initiative régionale qu'on
souhaitait découvrir c'est le projet
matrice je le disais tout à l'heure ça
va changer mais ça va changer pourquoi
et comment surtout en fait ça va changer
l'expérience de visite en fait fontenay
vous je voulait innover leurs circuits
et le numérique et surtout attirer de
nouveaux publics en fait oui hein je
pense que les jeunes tourisme c'est
parfois un peu compliqué entre le
patrimoine en fait c'est un mot qui fait
un peu peur ou est la plus jeune et la
solution s'était installé le numérique
et les nouvelles technologies de manière
générale au sein de ces lieux est ce
qu'on vient de voir ses seins à caton en
fête qui a eu lieu à paris en juin 4
c'est un sprint créatif
donc pendant trois jours les étudiants
étaient dans une salle à fléchir a
travaillé à mettre en place en fait leur
projet qu'ils ont ensuite présentés
devant un jury da corella le numérique
fait parler les vieilles pierres on le
voit les murs sont vos oreilles c'est ça
alors ça par exemple c'est une
application un réseau social sonore
géolocalisé en fait le visiteur pourra
se promener dans un lieu enregistré des
vocaux qui partagera sur une application
et en ce moment il pourra aussi écouter
les enregistrements sonores d'autres
promeneurs et quand vous racontez en
fait l'histoire des lieux c'est ça comme
ça peut exister dans certains grands
musées où il ya déjà de la réalité
virtuelle où on peut s'approcher des
oeuvres où on découvre presque le
peintre qui sort enfin et des choses
absolument extraordinaire il ya quand
même une volonté de ne pas dénaturer ces
lieux là puisque c'est des lieux qui ont
une histoire de plus de 900 ans et le
but c'est vraiment de mettre les
nouvelles technologies au sein d' enfin
au service d'une histoire de service du
patrimoine d'accord alors pour ceux qui
sont avec nous moi le premier j'imagine
aussi caroline c'est super on va pouvoir
en profiter quand le samedi 21 septembre
à l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
toutes les équipes de matrix reviennent
au château du clos de vougeot et à
l'abbaye de fontenay ils vont présenter
leur projet au grand public d'accord
avec un parcours sur nos géolocaliser
c'est à dire que on va le suivre et puis
en même temps de réaction c'est ça il y
aura de tout il y aura ces parcours ce
nom il y aura un plateau de jeu il
des de la réalité augmentée il y aura
des énigmes en fait il ya un projet qui
s'appelle in skype et celle inverse de
l'escap game on entre on résoudre des
énigmes pour rentrer à l'intérieur d'un
lieu et pas pour en sortir et ça le
public pourra tester le 21 septembre un
corps mais dites moi au départ vous
m'avez dit vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe c'est des étudiants donc c'est
quand même un sacré défi pour les
étudiants là il bascule presque dans la
mode en mode start up c'est ça en fait
de novembre à juin ils tous suivaient
leurs études quand même à côté donc il
devait me les matrices les partielles
parfois même des jobs étudiants les
parcelles sont quasiment terminées
maintenant on considère que ce ne sont
plus des étudiants mais on doit les apps
les entrepreneurs et les voilà voilà une
petite vingtaine mais en fait c'est une
vraie aventure humaine au delà d'une
aventure professionnelle
on a certains qu'on quitte et ont déjà
quitté l aventure les équipes ont bougé
les projets ont évolué et je pense que
d'ici septembre leur encore d'autres
d'autres choses à voir rassurez moi vous
allez suivre l'aventuré vous sur le web
sur les écrans connectés on se mettra
sur les plates formes de france
télévisions on pourra suivre tous mangé
depuis novembre déjà on peut le suivre
il ya une plusieurs articles sont en
ligne des vidéos
moi je communique régulièrement avec les
étudiants donc d'exiger de leurs
nouvelles je publie sur sur le site
internet de france 3 sur les réseaux
sociaux et le 21 septembre évidemment on
sera là pour suivre cette belle
conclusion une expérience inédite
pourrait dire la première fois c'était
sur france 3 je trouve ça plutôt plutôt
sympathique puisqu'on est dans le rayon
internet dite moi caroline internet joue
un rôle important dans votre métier
parce que avec le travail de chanteuse
lyrique parfois on a tendance peut-être
à vouloir copier je veux donner tout à
l'heure des grands noms la callas
pavarotti alagna pour les femmes
nathalie de ces notamment où cécilia
bartoli qui concernerait plus ou
montserrat caballe y est vous avez dû
certainement s'il ya un moment où vous
avez touché ce répertoire aller faire un
petit tour sur le net vous vous en
servez donato oui oui et c'est vraiment
précieux parce que ça nous donne accès
effectivement à ce matériau
audiovisuelle qui des fois était
difficile à retrouver alors je parle pas
des grands des grands classiques mais
même certains enregistrements un corps
art
de la callas ou d'autres artistes
maintenant sont accessibles par youtube
patience état grave
voilà et on peut effectivement chercher
plein de chose comparé des versions
chercher un arrangement et bien sûr
écouter les morceaux donc effectivement
c'est précieux mais recherché de
partitions force